si on est dans un dépistage tous azimuts
de tout le monde dans une entreprise un
matin en disant comme ça vous serez un
ça ne correspond pas à ça n'a pas de
sens au niveau médical et scientifique
pour les raisons que je vous disais vous
pouvez arriver à l'entreprise le lundi
et tout le monde et tout le monde est
négatif mais quelqu'un va se contaminer
en rentrant chez lui en faisant ses
courses le mardi ou mercredi
et puis vint et virulent entreprises on
fait quoi on recommence toutes les
semaines
si vous avez des gens qui sont
contaminés et donc potentiellement
contagieuse
ce qu'il faut c'est protéger le plus
grand nombre tout pour éviter que la
transmission se fasse donc identifier
toute personne malade identifier tous
les cas contacter toutes les personnes
qui ont été en contact prolongé et
rapprochés avec les personnes malades
allaient les dépister systématiquement
isolé qui doit être isolé
ça c'est la méthode qui fonctionne c'est
la méthode qui fonctionne et qui a un
impact sur le déroulé de l'épidémie
testez 65 millions de français tous les
jours voire deux fois par jour c'est un
non sens parce qu'on ne peut pas le
faire et que je vous garantis qu'on
aurait très peu de volontaires en
complément il y aura bientôt nous
l'espérons les tests sérologiques dont
on n'était pas sûr qu'il soit efficace
opérationnel est intéressant on commence
à éclaircir le brouillard on sait qu'à
priori ils seront intéressants on attend
on attend maintenant de savoir s'ils
sont opérationnels le gros labos que
j'ai vu ce matin qui a des dizaines de
machines high-tech qui sont vraiment un
autre top du top de ce qui existe me dit
lui-même
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas en état de
pouvoir faire des examens sérologiques
ans et en toute sécurité parce que je ne
sais pas ce qui fonctionne et ce qui ne
fonctionne pas